vous n'entendez que le son de ma voix
nous sommes dimanche le jour des
explications saluent alors non je vais
pas ouvrir une secte aujourd'hui mais
plutôt comme chaque dimanche vous
expliquer quelque chose qui va vous
permettre de bluffer les autres on a
souvent parlé dans les vidéos des
micromouvements musculaire même si j'ai
pas encore fait de master class dessus
d'ailleurs ça viendra plus tôt à partir
du mois de septembre ou avant peut-être
en juillet suivant le nombre de pouces
en l'air sur cette vidéo
c'est tellement du chantage à utiliser
la force de la suggestion et les micro
mouvements musculaires d'une personne
pour lui donner la sensation qu un
pendule peut recevoir ses pensées votre
seul rôle va être de suggérer que c'est
possible alors je vais pas vous donner
un tour particulier parce que c'est
applicable à plein de choses vous
pourriez demander à quelqu'un de choisir
une carte pouvez l'adapter à énormément
de choses on va parler d'une méthode que
vous pouvez faire n'importe où vous
demandez à une personne de sortir quatre
objets et de les mettre devant elle
ensuite vous lui demander d'écrire sur
un bout de papier l'objet qu'elle a
choisi dans sa tête si vous n'avez pas
tokyo l'écrit dans son téléphone par
exemple le seul but c'est de pouvoir rpt
et accéder à cette information plus tard
à la fin et vous lui confiez un pendule
alors ça c'est un vrai pendule un vrai
pendule à pas cher et ça marche pas
aussi bien en prenant une bague et en
l'attachant au bout d'une chaîne ou même
en attachant une gomme au bout dans la
selle le but du jeu c'est d'avoir
quelque chose de lourd au bout d'un
field vous demandez ensuite à la
personne de tenir le pendule de la
manière suivante un petit peu de la
chaîne à l'intérieur de la main la
repasse sur l'index et ça retombe de
l'autre côté on referme les doigts comme
ceci est en place le pouce dessus au
niveau de l'index pouvez également lui
faire tenir comme ceux ci mais alors
vraiment du bout du bout du bout de la
chaîne dans ce cas là la prise doit être
ferme par le haut et vous allez lui
suggérer par votre discours il n'y a pas
de discours écrit parce que pas de bon
ou de mauvais discours le seul but c'est
d'avoir une attention de suggestions
pour lui faire penser réellement que le
pendule va bouger au dessus de l'objet
qu'elle a choisi elle-même
vous lui demander de passer le pendule
sur chaque objet un vrai temps de
prendre vraiment son temps quelques
secondes au dessus de chaque objet ça
peut être 10 secondes à chaque fois par
exemple un vrai moment et quand le
pendule est au dessus d'un objet voulu
rappeler que si c'est l'objet qu'elle a
choisi alors le pendule va se mettre à
bouger et à chaque objet vous allez lui
rappeler que si c'est l'objet qu'elle a
choisi mentalement et qu'elle a écrit
dans son portable sur un bout de papier
alors le pendule va se mettre à bouger
il va se mettre à bouger de plus en plus
rapidement de plus en plus vite de plus
en plus rapidement et si le pendule se
mettent à bouger et que vous lui faites
passer à
notre objet alors le pendule va
s'arrêter il va s'arrêter parce qu'il
sait que ce n'est pas l'objet que c'est
votre suggestion qui va provoquer de
micro mouvement c'est une suggestion
très puissante et très bluffante à
utiliser encore une fois y'a pas de
script précis prenez bien cette
attention là vous devez juste répéter
que cissé lô que j'ai choisi alors le
pont du leu a bougé si c'est pas l'objet
choisi alors le pendule va rester fixe
dans la grande grande très grande
majorité des cas sauf fonctionnera très
bien parce que la personne a envie que
ça marche alors envie de voir ça et dès
que ça va commencer à osciller elle va
se convaincre que c'est par rapport à ce
que vous avez dit que ça bouge et le
fait qu'elle se dit ça alors son cerveau
va envoyer encore une fois de micro
mouvements qui vont accentuer encore le
mouvement du pendule et c'est un circuit
comme sa vertu j'espère que ce tour un
petit peu spécial vous aura plu surtout
que vous aller l'essayer n'hésitez pas
prenez confiance en vous faites-le
amusez vous avec vous pouvez très bien
l'adapter à un jeu de cartes moi je me
fais comme ça j'ai même envie de dire ça
va vous bluffez vous même j'espère donc
que ça vous a plu que vous le ferez si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à me le faire
savoir en laissant un petit pouce en
l'air et en me disant dans les
commentaires comment ça s'est passé je
serais très curieux de lire ça
exceptionnellement demain bien conscient
lundi ce sera pas un blog on parlera
d'un truc geek mais terrible en
attendant passer un excellent dimanche
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner rendez
vous demain à 17 heures ciao